the first season of Jackass I wasn't
even paid per episode I was paid per bit
oh we didn't get paid at all the first
season you didn't get paid not one penny
we worked at the T-shirt shop so we got
200 a week oh so that was actually a
real thing you guys actually held a job
and yeah they paid us 200 a week and
that's what we got whoa and 200 to me
I'm getting every single Friday I felt
freaking rich because you know none of
us had money like that Looking Back Now
I'm like oh my God we never got paid for
the first season so that means you're
smarter than I am
what what because we got paid for bid it
was 200 bucks if it wasn't dangerous and
it was 500 bucks if it was dangerous I
made less than 1500 bucks after taxes
for the first season